[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going bros my name is peter
pack
today we're viewing a brand new
subreddit called
uh ape i've never seen it before oh my
god
no it just it just clicked it just it
just clicked
okay all right maybe it's just monkeys
okay who knows
i'm a 14 year old monkey and i am cancer
uh-huh you finally awake that fall look
really bad industrial society humans
what are you talking about let's go eat
ants
but if it was all a dream what if the
industrial revolution was all
just a dream oh my god she's literally
me
um what is this subreddit man destroys
monkey creates all right the election
results greg
good for greg no you you can't just bite
off my nose and maul me to death
rank of hamstrings
monkey monkey average banana fan
versus average coconut enjoyer monkey no
oh he's back i returned to repair this
shattered world
all right let's look at this instead
it's a classic reddit and i never
reviewed it
i think it's pretty funny this is one of
the biggest surveys called starter packs
ready post that no longer makes me start
a pack painting done in under a minute
yeah
opening an ammonite fossil i never seen
that what the
pencil drawing that looks like a photo
yeah
this specific part of this sculpture
i got three out of four at least you've
seen it too many times even though it's
amazing it's like yeah
i get it empty wrapping paper tube
starter pack
i don't get it empty wrapping paper why
am i dumb is it because you can hear the
sound effects
[Laughter]
no it isn't i'm so confused i'm sure the
comments will tell me
dad checking in on you during a
depressive episode starter pack
are you winning son hey champ
want to talk about it buddy you should
let some more light in here door opener
closed i got that one
my dad would always ask me that that's
so sweet
oh doesn't really understand why you're
sad but it doesn't try either
picks up a random toy obviously in your
room hey i haven't seen one of these in
years
i only got the door open and closed i
can relate to that really hard
staring at the car window as a kid's
starter pack blinking each time the car
lines up with a telephone pole what i
never done that
trying to keep your eyes straight but
then somehow always focus on a distant
object yeah yeah
okay sure imagining a superhero yeah
[ __ ] mowgli from from uh the jungle
book i imagine for some reason
thank you brain uh that you see you
missed the point by idolizing them
starter pack
am i in there no all right
i find it fascinating how so many
characters that are supposed to be
cool still do these horrible heinous
[ __ ]
like so many people idolize patrick
bateman man kill the [ __ ] dog dude
you missed the point cringe they're
actually
bad bet you didn't understand that
you like american psycho but you missed
the point of the whole thing
all right when he brutally murdered
women adding i didn't
i just flew past my head wow
[Laughter]
things i thought were huge problems when
i was a kid oh my god
quicksand yeah
i still think it's a problem because i
still don't know what to do
how many people died from quick i gotta
know this how many people die from
quicksand a year how many people
none well that's disappointing
everything i ever know is a lie
the idea that you could get sucked under
this effort coming no i've heard people
die from quicksand
it happened in uk yeah british woman
there you go
yeah it happens yeah not to me and not
to you because we know what to do
yeah what was i doing right starter pack
my bad
if you meet loch ness the luck nets
whatever his name is her
nessie uh you're done yeah chokehold i
don't know
1960's american scientist yes
it could be me he mustache i am muslim
i'm a scientist guys what can i say i'm
kind of a scientist myself
[Laughter]
the shoes you wearing when your mom
tells you to take out the trash starter
pack
i love this this is reminiscent of
experiences that i've shared with people
that i would never ever think about
and yes this did happen to me in sweden
we have these wood shoes do you have
those
you don't have those in the states i
don't know why but they're so
good this is like pre-crocs era you know
you're taking
trash out if you're wearing one of these
bad boys in sweden
why oh they're from netherlands you know
you meant business
when you put on the wooded shoes what's
the history behind that
i'm not gonna lie i kinda wanna buy some
wood shoes this whole subreddit is just
one giant tangent isn't it
we invented the crocs first you're
welcome i mean
am i i don't know crew in space movies
start a pack three x one x one x one
hit that diversity pack let's go the
class clown had a home starter pack
hey i was a class clown and i had no
problems at home huh explain that
scientist oh wait that's me
uh i remember in school some kid some of
my friends would be like
oh yeah you will totally be like a talk
show host or something in the future
and i was like damn that's impossible
and then
it sort of happened but not really yeah
which is weird actually because i'm so
introverted that not all boomers are bad
starter pack
none of these are boomers what oh really
jk's on that
when was this posted 11 months ago all
right
thinks your brain says you gotta do
starter pack
bend it more
[Laughter]
give her a spin click it click click
press it at least three times right you
can't just press it once
only one i really relate to is bend it
more and click the clock what else
shove your hands into it yeah slide it
as you walk
no grab some of them lethal bros
yeah leafy bro yeah you gotta grab a
leak
that rock i gotta kick it
brain you gotta do it bruh you gotta do
it disney humor started by a very
attractive female that's
somehow a loser always wanted a pet pig
a character that's annoyingly dumb a
character that has 200 iq and knows the
useless fact yeah that's pretty much it
that's comedy right there we can't think
of anything else any other character
tropes or traits nah
[Laughter]
unskippable game cinematic starter pack
have you tried alt f4 come on
i've never been to america but this is
probably how it is uh i've been to
america and that
is how it is you start a pack as tall as
your height
prefer to eat foods you like rather than
those you dislike yeah that's true
born at least once yeah i can't fault
that enjoy your interests
i do like mainstream how do they know
what the flipped it
hey things that everyone knows but the
fan base treats it as is unheard of
[Laughter]
really me it's for me
be hard with pewdiepie he's a little
something what
that's kind of dope i'll take that as a
compliment we're still
indie guys maybe one day we'll make it
on this channel
non-native english speaker starter pack
sorry my english is terrible
cambridge assessment english c2
proficiency
sorry for my english for i am not a
native speaker and cannot elicit from my
mind all the exquisite
lexicon as i had hoped dude why
no no no no
no no okay if anything the
opposite ah someone has lived in uk for
eight years
oh it's all right don't worry i know
you're i know you don't
your first language is in english what
the [ __ ] does that mean i speak perfect
english
i get it all the time it's all right
it's not english is not your first time
guys speaking i spoke stuff
dude get the [ __ ] out of here piss me
off
jesus sure i can text and drive at the
same time start a
pack be right there bro oh my god
don't text him drive ever things you are
not allowed to like according to
reddit's artifact who the
likes t-series no disney you like what
are you [ __ ] adult
cringe what i mean what are your [ __ ]
child you like
fortnite kids like fortnite nah
nah get the guy out of here girl who
breaks up with you
because you won't stop eating french
onion soup in bed starter pack
stop seriously weeping over this amanda
please come back i'm sorry
is this a reference things people like
to feel weirdly superior about starter
pack being vegan yeah
hating children also having children no
i just hate children
okay i'm not a hypocrite jogging
no not getting any sleep no
disliking popular movie franchise oh
that's
me damn it waking up early now
not drinking i don't need drinks to have
fun well i don't drink but i'm not an
[ __ ] about it
okay uh can't relate to this but i
imagine you guys can
roast me starter pack
do your worst reddit i think it's worse
when it's just someone looking very
normal
it's like okay well what the do you want
hey pewdiepie submissions
how users are in these subreddits
[Laughter]
yes it's true you guys are nine actually
this is outdated you should be 19 what
the [ __ ]
surprise was so many pewdiepie
submission the american teen being late
for school starter peg
the only one i can think of is japanese
when they run with a toast in their
mouth right
come on we've all done that at some
point
that one girl in every school marching
band starter pack
it's you cringe it's you
see you will never find me in here you
will never find me because i'm not a
cliche
okay so okay i was wrong i am
in the starter pack six five yep
yep 200 yeah a little more like yeah
fortunate yet yep sorry i guess i was
wrong guys that's embarrassing
a new study starter pack red meat is uh
good or
bad uh alcohol is a good air bet there
it goes
yes uranium good bad
god it's like why you stop listening to
all this [ __ ]
oh you're an all meat diet it's actually
better oh it's actually good
make up your [ __ ] mind scientists
were all these scientists coming up with
all these ideas huh
[ __ ] i swear to be fair the the most
annoying one
which one is it uh squarespace isn't it
why would i need a website in 2020 all
right
you want to make it look a website so
easy to make you guys won't you have a
website
yeah just of course you want a website
oh i better sign up i had to make
a website yeah i need a website that's
what i need
i love a lot of youtubers do that too
they're like guys check out my website
it's like youtube but my website you
watch it on youtube on my webs it's my
website
check out my website you can watch all
the youtube videos on
but it's mine and uh website
the one video on europe's scare tech
problem that actually fixes
its startup time yes and that song
it always happens like i can't sing
once i see that text pack show up a text
doc
i know i know what they're doing and an
indian accent let's get real here that's
not uh
that's just the truth okay things we all
did as kids starter pack let's see how
many we get
okay drew the sun check uh-huh the only
eraser
why yeah check for that of course
brandon smoke
pressing both sides down at once
uh-huh yeah yeah what the [ __ ] is that
ew no
no yeah
drew so yeah yeah yes
yes no no
all right how many you get the clip on
the mouth yeah
why the hell did i do that paintball
why past is still do nice
oh look hair clipper thing must put on
mouth
second choice of starter pack pepsi
burger king
ethereum
[Laughter]
oh here we go reddit normie starter pack
pewdiepie submissions thank me memes
insta-enormous tick-tock bad
fortnite bad minecraft good yeah bad
things bad
bad things bad but something's good bad
fights for twenty
six nine funny yeah definitely
definitely break dick right and worship
these
damn eh oh
[ __ ] they got us
that i don't do well in school but talk
about quantum physics starter pack
i can't stop thinking of quantum physics
i just can't help myself
thank you for teaching me a bunch of
knowledge i will never need to know
starter pack i didn't ask this question
but i still clicked on the video
and i still will never have any use for
it thank you starter pack
this style jane 30 years that's so
interesting
damn it remember bees
ah come on the s is still uh the s is
still nostalgic get the [ __ ] out of here
uh the pewdiepie fan starter pack here
we go
jojo my hair academy i've never even
seen it creeper oh man
[Laughter]
i feel like this isn't accurate some
parts it thinks that he invented
chairs or something
yeah yeah these are bad because
they have more subscribers than him yeah
yeah but coco melon bag come on get with
the times
i like how they threw the meatball in
there i appreciate that annoying reddit
starter pack
there we go again either hates or love
pewdiepie never in between yeah
loves anime pretends to hate it
that's me all right that's really fun i
like that subreddit
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
subscribe it's
friday thanks for watching guys see you
tomorrow bro face
[Music]